say goodbye to drills as a new cavity
filling technique that uses electrical
current could be available to the public
in three years and a fungus in the soil
of Nova Scotia has been found to help
combat antibiotic resistant superbugs
so on behalf of the rest of the world
thank you Canadian dirt Vsauce Kevin
here this is fun
the crews rp1 is the first highway
autopilot for your car the device keeps
your car and it's laying a safe distance
from the car in front of you it is
always watching the road even if you
aren't it can be installed on your
existing vehicle so you can sit back and
let the car do the work by controlling
the steering throttle and braking and
they're taking pre-orders for 2015 right
now the cosy room lets you hide from
everything
the Japanese relaxation room comes with
space for a TV or computer shelves to
display collections and a personal desk
it costs eight thousand dollars but
unfortunately doesn't include plumbing a
refrigerator or air-conditioning pelty
is a high-quality speaker that runs off
the power from a single wax candle
it turns the thermal energy from the
candle into enough electric energy to
power the speaker and amplify the music
and it has no wires and connects via
bluetooth making an eco-friendly and
easy to transport a group of chimps have
created a fashion trend when popular
chimp Julie stuck a piece of grass in
her ear back in 2010 it caught on with
all the other chimps now they're all
doing it so yeah the ReWalk is the first
fda-approved exoskeleton for use in the
home and in the community the robotic
device enables hip and knee motion
allowing those with spinal cord injuries
to stand when the user tilts forward the
walking motion is activated and repeated
shifting creates a sequence of steps the
ReWalk has the ability to sit stand turn
and climb stairs giving paraplegics
extensive mobility options to explore
Etta is a human powered bike capable of
going a hundred and 33.8 km/h and it
looks like a giant bullet on wheels the
rider sits comfortably inside and uses
this
Blaz from cameras to see the road it
won't be able to be used on highways
anytime soon due to its inability to
survive a collision and low visibility
but they hope that in the future this
technology could be used for a cleaner
alternative to driving engineers at the
University of Illinois are creating
biobots these biological robots are
powered by muscle cells and controlled
with electrical impulses they're using
skeletal muscle cells because of their
ability to be controlled making it
possible to customize each box for a
specific task or application this is the
first step in developing biological
machines that can be programmed and
trained to do work Luke butcher of
Cambridge believes skinny wormholes
could be kept stable long enough to send
a beam of light carrying a message
anywhere in the universe or throughout
time itself this is theoretical but
awesome smart bricks are like giant Lego
for building houses bridges and
sidewalks the large concrete tight
bricks are designed to be easily joined
together and the company claims these
building materials provide a 50%
reduction in building costs and they
hope to implement the technology
everywhere from africa to manhattan
british airways created a happiness
blanket it changes color to reflect the
mood of the wearer by measuring
electrical fluctuations with the
headband and sending the information to
fiber-optic lights woven into the fabric
with red meaning stressed and blue
meaning relaxed they use this
information to test changes they made on
boards such as entertainment and
sleeping options so they could see the
actual physical effects these had on
passengers the eco cycle is a 3d printer
that uses post-consumer waste as
printing material each cartridge turns
three twenty ounce plastic bottles into
anything from accessories to decorations
and they say it's not just a tool for
making but remaking things and changing
the way people think about recycling
finally confluence is a short film using
macro and microscopes shot in 4k with a
red cam
I'm gonna leave you with a crash proof
drone and as always thanks for watching